cool we're InFocus everything yes we are
sir we didn't clap do it who is this man
to my right this is a director producer
dapper clothing wear extraordinaire
Krampus enthusiast check Faria hi
everyone he and I filmed a urine review
sort of episode of not too deep that you
should go listen to over on iTunes or
SoundCloud after you watch us play the
challenge challenge challenge challenge
we thought it was appropriate since it's
the end of the year to look back in
challenge form on some of the challenges
that we've done here on not too deep we
have all of the guests that we've had on
the podcast on note cards in front of us
what's gonna happen is a producer for a
day Mitchell Davis it's gonna read off
one of the challenges that we've done
here on not too deep and Jack and I are
gonna have to guess which guest was
participating in that challenge so
should we play to five points let's
let's do that we'll see how it goes
play to five points great okay Mitchell
if you will okay so the first one that
I'm gonna do uh-huh is the shock ball
challenge oh yeah yes Nikki limo but so
you don't get tape on your face I just
get a point that's right I feel like
we're gonna be really good at this the
eventually that was a very quick oh who
won the challenge oh I oh my god this
part I don't know I think that Nikki won
that challenge nice one that channel oh
I've never been so disappointed in my
own victory okay so now you get to take
my face sweet but you're still winning
that's the thing that's ironic
well no no never on this show are the
challenges with winners but straight up
to the hair so I'm going to get the hair
first piece of tape into the hair yeah
it's got to feel different cuz usually
always taping our hands and now you're
just going straight for the face this is
enough does this look okay don't feel
like a Vulcan thank you
live long and prosper okay what's our
next time for the next challenge yeah
there we go
speech jammer challenge oh that was Jack
oh one grace one grace did a very good
job me does that mean I get two points
see this there's so many points okay
we'll play to ten you get two points yes
okay ready you guys ready yes the Ginga
challenge
Oh Oh jack takes you to get Jack Jack oh
I couldn't find his car sorry my eyes
are limited right now on that challenge
guys that's Jack who won that challenge
grace won that show Jenny diffic time
Elliot won that challenge I don't
remember look me in the eyeball
Oh God on that look how that look on
camera good right right up the bat three
two one right 3-1 okay Oh amazing
our next guest is about to walk in the
door and the urban dictionary challenge
off oh damn it's red one the one Jenna
Janet yeah okay it's three two three mmm
the no arms challenge
oh no no arms challenge I know this I
know cuz it yeah Debbie go Jack hey
Kimmy rode on very long where's the name
who are you looking for amber you
tweeted with your feet oh yes yes yeah
and deeply repressed laughing from the
past so uh Emma won she did mother fu
got five points go ahead and take my
face yes all right
oh god that feels great it feels great
that feels great
I feel pretty beautiful it's so good
thank you guys are my best friends
the next challenge is the Edward spooky
hands challenge with spooky James Edward
spooky or is it disgrace got it 'don't
ah don't let her
guess it I know I see it yeah isn't it
this part suck a lot bad oh my god Hey
seven six make a guess five no hang on
that's it three two oh oh wow
took you long enough there bro yeah
sorry I who won great a one big time I
want big time did I make the most
eventful mummy I've ever made that day
it's tied up five to five let's do this
you deserve a stink challenge oh oh oh
dammit dammit
yeah damn right one grace this father no
mother don't mind us with two monsters
have a great song oh no this is where it
all falls apart okay feels great oh
welcome to your nightmare
yeah yeah yeah let's go
the bean boozled challenge oh yeah the
one oh oh come on Jack Oh grace oh yeah
yeah it's my loss a lot of hair in my
face you gentle okay open your mouth
okay here we go okay I can't see you
don't want to see this Jack you look
good what to say anything challenge oh I
have no idea say anything say anything
oh um Sadie Oh challenge that was both
were there yes five five three shouts
the water remember France
we played the tape alright cuz you look
like a monster you oh yeah so I could
choose who won yeah one the one grace I
won
grace did woo Yes Mother Oh God okay you
get escape on the bar do this okay lower
lip please good it's getting really fun
to take off hey good oh you guys are
gonna win the thumbnail game yeah hope
so next challenge is traditional media
ah the soda pong challenge oh I know
this ah no dammit dammit great who won
ah can yes and guess who just won this
whole challenge you get one piece of
tape because you lost is a new rule says
the winner we hold the ear down oh good
that's great yeah all the way around so
if you didn't have nightmares currently
you got him I can't see a thing now okay
yeah this needs to end before I have
nightmares yeah you asked for it and you
got it jack fairy on an episode of not
too deep make sure the you listen to
focus on not too deep on soundcloud or
iTunes for old Jack Fairy 99 on the
Twitter see if we can get him that day
with Rachel McAdams how could she not
want to date this Rachel this is what
you're missing out on get it girl
I don't know I think probably freeze
time
oh but like you can move within time of
course naturally if I froze two that
would tear it be the worst power would
make any sense